toujours le tigre est peut-être d'avoir
une soeur et seulement pas l'accident
libraire 1-2 dans twitter on rit
tranquille était bien plus qu'un simple
libraires c'était un phare dans la
grande noirceur
c'est chez lui quand été lancé le
manifeste du refus global c'est le
prochain
de grands thermes c'est comme ça que
j'aime l'appeler parce qu'il faut que
des livres ccc des invitations voyage
marcel barbeau anne hébert hubert acket
réjean ducharme sa boutique était le
rendez vous d'une jeunesse assoiffée de
liberté
cette librairie était non pas juste une
pépinière mais un endroit de
rassemblement place forte
un endroit où pouvaient s'élaborer
certaines stratégies de création de
publication un lieu politique fondée en
1937 la librairie son propriétaire ont
été déterminants pour plusieurs auteurs
c'est grâce à lui qu'ils beauchemin a
publié son premier roman
l'amphi roi paix refusé par toutes les
maisons d'édition il lui antoine nuit
survenu à la librairie il m'a dit ça il
faut que ça soit édité téléphone dans
l'instant quai qui dirige à l'époque les
éditions la presse et lui a ordonné des
18 monts lives à lorsque franck et avec
un sourire en coin dit oui sûrement oui
est ce que vous me permettez de lire le
manuscrit avant de publier
j'ai probablement aimait trop les livres
pour être un bras comme aptes à sa
librairie a fait faillite en 1975
mais son nom continue de s'afficher en
toutes lettres sur la rue
sainte-catherine la ville rebaptisera
l'esplanade clark esplanade tranquille
un nom qui aura un double sens pour
cartes quartier des spectacles
tranquille pour henri traquer la grêle
et tranquille qui est en même temps
tranquille parce que le lieu est un
petit peu en retrait de la place
espéraient de la place des spectacles
alors on aimait bien le parallèle de sa
bouche d'un côté et de l'autre côté on
se repose un peu plus il va avoir un
beau chalet sera trop lieu de
découvertes de rencontres peur on aimait
bien le petit clin d'oeil l'esplanade
tranquille devrait être inauguré l'an
prochain ici nabi alexandre charti radio
canada montréal